the rock legends are now making film
history with director Katia Fong Garnier
for three whole years they were followed
by a camera as they toured the world the
result is the documentary forever and a
day
it's the Scorpions as they've never been
seen before it was a challenge to roll
all the fascinating moments and stories
into one to choose them while never
losing sight of what this is all about
and he has an ounce of remorse
magnificant an image capturing a spirit
of the band after Schwartz accom the
film looks at much more than just the
glamour and success there are moments of
exhaustion and grief like when Klaus
minor sings
after the death of his mother
what keeps our band together for so many
years via food and and Finn people might
get a better understanding of how we see
things and how we feel if they see this
movie they might understand a bit better
why we're still out there forever in the
day is a tribute to a great band that's
not giving up after decades on the road
it shows why the scorpions are one of
the biggest names in rock